Elizabeth is in Grand Rapids Michigan I
Elizabeth how are you I'm fine how are
you Dave
better than I deserve what's up um my
question today is we in April we
completed F to you but we've lived in
crisis modes for so long we're having a
hard time just getting on that written
budget we'll stick to it for a week then
something will happen and so we're just
continuing getting it in crisis mode no
I don't what happens what happens just
like birthdays come up or Mother's Day
you know in May so just why was that why
was that not anticipated and put into
the budget which that should have been
okay so your budget was incomplete
you've not gotten good at budgeting yet
yeah cuz mother's days not Mother's Day
it's not exactly a freakin crisis no I
guess it's not a crisis okay another
crisis but to me it feels like a crisis
because we can't meet our bills so I
guess I guess the budget how do you
stick with it what's the disappoint well
number one it has to be realistic and
what you've laid out from he's not
realistic so whose birthday her daughter
okay well you knew the birthday was this
month so the budget was not realistic
because you didn't have the birthday in
the budget right and so the budget has
to be it has to really reflect what's
really going on in the house and to say
we're gonna have a little kid and do 0/4
birthday is not reality now the way do
we do it birthday cheap right now
because we're getting out of debt yeah
probably but but we got to do something
for the kid I mean so we that has to be
in this month's budget Mother's Day most
days and Father's Day while you're on a
budget getting out that don't have to be
much but at least we admit that it's
there and you know maybe that is the one
time we go out to eat or something for
lunch after church or otherwise we go
home any leftovers but or whatever I
mean you couldn't figure these things
out but you just plan them out and
otherwise what you do is if something
does pop up that is unexpected
those shouldn't be unexpected but that
is unexpected then you sit down together
and you say all right we have a $50 item
here what other categories are we going
to lower by a total of $50 so that the
budget still balances because we're not
in Congress we can't just keep spending
well that's and that's kind of how I
feel right now yeah and so are you
trying to do this by yourself without
your husband yeah yeah that's not that's
your other problem yeah it's almost
impossible to do it by yourself yeah and
you're carrying the weight and he's just
kind of rolling his eyes and doing
whatever the flip he wants to do while
you're trying to be really hard oh shut
up he can work hard and help his wife
with a budget it's not a big deal I mean
we all work hard I'm not saying he's a
bad guy I'm saying he's not
participating in this process yeah okay
and you're carrying this part of the
load by yourself and it's very very hard
to do it's almost impossible and so did
he go through Financial Peace University
with you David
okay so he took an hour two hours nine
different times oh I'm sorry
hey mister okay seven different times
okay it doesn't take that long to do a
budget right and so the two of you get
every dollar on your Android or your
iPhone I have and sit down where is he
got it on his phone no tablet okay well
it's on the tablet then the two of you
sit down together go over it together
and agree to stick to it but he's put
99.9 percent of the weight of this on
you
so you're forgetting stuff and the
budgets incomplete and he's not
emotionally helping you carry the weight
of all these decisions right and when
those two things come together I think
your budget it'll take a month or two
for it to get right because you don't do
a budget perfectly for about 90 days but
I think it'll come together for you if
you'll keep leaning on it matter of fact
I know it well but the budget has to
reflect what's really going on in the
month has to be an accurate picture of
what's really going on
and of course we have to cut some of the
stupid spending out that we've been
doing so we've got some money to attack
some these other things and you know he
can find time to go financial university
can find time to sit down with you go
for this budget hey thanks for calling
now puts this hour that ever MZ show in
the books hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]